all right Billy yes Billy uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm from uh Charleston West Virginia on
big Tower Road
tell me about your childhood you grew up
with both your parents yeah I grew up
with both my parents uh right up here
above his trailer in a little one-room
house
how would you describe your your
childhood
I had a good childhood I was an only
child and I you know had a good
childhood
how far are you in school I didn't go to
school until the 10th grade and I got
kicked out the first year for fighting
hmm
what kind of stuff were you getting into
after that
well they they sent me to what's called
Cowboy dog up on Florida Street uptown
and I went up there and I started
fighting too uh just about every day and
you didn't have to go uh you know they
had no Authority up there you just
checked yourself out and I started
drinking liquor
and not getting out smoking weed and
doing a little angel dust whatever
and uh drugs become you're a part of
your life at some point
at some point uh in my later part of my
life when I first started messed
everything it was just liquor beer wine
and a little bit of weed and like I said
little angel with us here and there and
some LSD just progressed from there it
eventually got into what like heroin or
something I didn't get into the heroin I
didn't inject any dope or drugs up until
I was 48 years old and my mom started
dying of cancer and uh I started doing a
little injection and heroin and
oxycontin and stuff like that and I
didn't start smoking cigarettes till I
was 48. is that right how old are you
now I'm 57 57. and you've stayed here in
uh West Virginia yesterday in West
Virginia have you traveled I have
traveled
my mom and my stepdad uh have a house I
had two houses now my mom's like I said
it's gone but my stepdad has two houses
now down in Monterey Way Down in Arizona
okay
do you like this part of the country you
love it here this is my home I do love
it here but uh I don't have anything
here anymore I've lost my wife for 31
years and both my mom and dad are gone
and uh I really don't have anything here
that's keeping me here I keep saying I
want to leave and go back down West or
go up uh in the mountains of Tucker
County black waterfall somewhere in the
mountains yeah and and
throughout your adult life what kind of
stuff were you doing oh my God
every night I would get I was getting
out and drinking and going to These Bars
and stuff and running with the biker
gangs and fighting two and three times a
night uh you know I just wonder I didn't
get a real long stretch in the joint but
uh I did that's a prison time yeah I did
get a little pull back in the 80s uh I
got convicts of uh beating you guys a
ball bat
uh the three guys took me up to uh
Quincy and tried to get me uh you know
shots with what they've done
and I took a ball bat when I got inside
out they've nonchalantly used to have to
be a ball bat in the corner and I got a
hold of the ball bat and I like to kill
all three of them
and I meant to kill the guy that they
had set up up there with a gun won't
kill me so they give me one to five
I've done two and a half good times
do you have kids of your own no sir I
don't okay but you were married I was
married for 31 years I never did go get
divorced from my wife uh I was hoping
she'd straighten up and come back home
they found her May the 30th three years
ago I did what was that from
uh heroin over there uh yeah
so tell me about the uh
the swastika tattoo you've got on your
own uh well that's something I got when
I was in the joint and uh I got with the
ab of huttonville and you know they took
care of me when you're in the joints you
know you gotta you gotta side up or
either you know you end up getting hurt
and uh that's where I got that back in
82. so it's not necessarily your belief
system as much as it was just a prison
yeah
Community or group that you were in it's
a group that was pretty strong in there
yeah
and what do you make of the the future
of of Appalachia you know the drugs seem
to be so
out of control now they are and poverty
seems to be as bad as ever yeah back
when I was growing up you never seen
anyone walking around with uh backpacks
uh on their back and not not having no
place to stay homeless now it's it's uh
you see it everywhere and not only that
usually if you see someone with a
backpack and say they're homeless
they're hooked on Heroin some of them
working doing side jobs and has money
every week's buying them or not buying
for the rent of a place
and they just didn't put the dope up her
arm yeah but it's a it's a huge part
problem here it's an epidemic yeah yeah
it's rare to find a family or house that
isn't affected by it it is and you know
I'm not one to judge no one but I see
all this happening yeah and it's such a
it's a such a beautiful part of the
country it is and then you have this
going on yeah if you scratch the surface
and it's an interesting mix yeah and now
you know Charleston West Virginia it's
it's all over but uh now like Huntington
and different spots like down that way
is where a lot of the dealers come in
from out of state and they stay and and
like no names being mentioned because
people around here that goes down to
Huntington and gets it uh and you know
you see it on the news all the time but
uh it's it's a bad thing down there a
lot of people dying yeah
are you religious do you believe in God
yes I do you do yes I do
I know if it wasn't for that man up
there
giving me grace and mercy I'd be been
going a long time ago
dear friends
yeah I have I have some friends uh you
know I can count them on my my one hand
uh you know I really can
what are your biggest regrets
my biggest progress is uh
the the things that I've done in the
past with bad things and uh getting on
the alcohol and the drugs and uh
you know
I I I I can't say racing dirt bikes and
getting all broke up because I did enjoy
that but getting out drinking and
getting in these car wrecks and getting
hurt and a lot of the injuries I've got
is from fighting you know I've been
stabbed numerous times and you know I've
had a lot of
love grace and mercy by the Lord
you get depressed sometimes
what emotions do you go through oh yeah
I get depressed and not only that I've
got high anxiety uh you know I the
anxiety is worse than anything I I feel
like sometimes this trailer is shutting
on me you know I need to move up here
hold on a sec
that's stopping where is it
sure
another pathetic
see if we get stopping starting I think
we're okay
it's just water yeah
okay
look at that all right problem solved
yeah homemade umbrella
[Applause]
what do you worry about
uh I worry about my health these days uh
you know I worry about my health a lot
I'm getting up up and all the old
injuries and stuff I've had there's
catching up with me
and other than that I'll be honest with
you I have learned and I have trained
myself not to let other stuff worry me
like I used to because you know it's the
number one day of stress is the number
one death stressing yeah and if I would
sit around and worry about everything
that's going on around me and stuff that
I've been through I would drive myself
bad [ __ ] crazy
so you've spent the majority of your
life kind of what people would describe
as a Hellraiser yeah and yeah where do
you think that comes from because you
say your childhood was pretty well I'll
tell you uh my dad and me sit down I
don't know probably 15 years ago
and he he talked to me about the
drinking and the fighting and he said
you know Billy I think I know well you
got this crazy [ __ ] and I said where's
that Dad and he said your grandpa
Goodson he said nobody knew where he
come from nobody knew where he was born
he was from Virginia and he was a steel
worker and he drunk he was a little man
and he drunk whiskey and and he would
come home from the bars and my grandma
had eight kids uh five of them I think
was boys and he would come home and jump
on Grandma and and you know when the
boys got old enough they all started
ganging up on him and and you know
whooping his butt when he was and he
died of cancer before I was old enough
to ever sing
Ted Gibson was his name
and the the biker
gangs that you were in tell me without
getting in into too many specifics what
that
what kind of life that was
well uh you know uh it was a rough life
uh you know
uh I never was patched up uh but uh run
at a young age with different gangs I
knew a lot of older guys that was in
different biker games and not only you
know did I get with them at times and
run with them and go to their big jokes
and stuff like that I knew a lot of them
on personal
uh uh level and I would go
to different ones and and you know stay
weekends and party and drink and raise
hell listen to music you know and uh
had a good time back then but you know
you just had to watch your p's and q's
and Dot your eyes across your teeth or
you end up with one ear cut off or
something you know
if you could have lived your life
differently what would you have done
actually live my life differently I try
to stay in school
I graduate and get a good job I have
good good trades I was a I was a Mason
by trade my dad taught me how to lay
block brick but so you know
I I never did when I was younger I get
jobs good jobs and back then I thought
not paying into the government just
getting cash money was the way to go and
now here I said
throwing 700 some damn dollars a month
can't even hardly survive and back then
I was making 700 a day laying block you
know
so I would do that different I I was I
would have turned all my my earnings
into Social Security and and stuff and
I'll be drawing pretty good check now
you know
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
most important lesson I've learned in my
life
and this is not no [ __ ] is to stay
away from The Damn alcohol and the drugs
and to try to grow when you're growing
up go to school get your education and
get you a good job because this whole
world out here is a rough [ __ ]
and it don't care who it hurts or or
when it doesn't the people in it and
it's getting worse and that being said
if you're not out running these streets
with these type of people and just doing
this type kind of stuff you you need to
be get at a good job where you can have
a good life
that's what I would do different I
wouldn't be running with I wouldn't run
with the people I didn't do the drugs
and the bad [ __ ] I I was having a good
job or at least how hat would have had a
good job and be drawing a good pension
now
that's what I would do different and I
would tell all of these youngins and
young younger people
God whatever you do whatever you do
listen to this old man because I've
walked in steps and I know what I know
what's what's out there bad [ __ ] if you
don't
go down the right road so stay away from
me more people and
and doing these old bad things I'm
telling you right now you'll prosper and
you'll be glad you did
all right Billy thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome sir I wish you the best
of luck thank you I appreciate it and
you take care thank you all right
[Applause]